CBS News medical contributor dr. David
agus has been in contact with the White
House about the corona virus and he
joins us from Los Angeles to discuss the
federal government's response and also
getting enough medical supplies to
tackle the virus doctor good morning I'd
like to begin with something people have
not heard a lot about and that is the
possibility of an antibody test to tell
if the virus has been in somebody's
system how would that work and why why
might it be helpful well you know across
the country now many people are having
mild symptoms and they're told to stay
at home because of the shortage of tests
and they're not being tested and so at
some point you'd have to know whether
you were exposed to the virus or not and
in the next several weeks this test will
be launched hopefully it's even sooner
and the power is if you've been exposed
what we know it is for several months at
least we don't know long-term but
several months you are immune to the
virus if you've already been exposed and
recovered so when it says we could
create a cohort of workers across the
country to be the ambulance drivers to
check out to the cat at the grocery
stores working in the emergency rooms
who won't get sick if they're exposed
again to the virus so this test is
critical to round two of fighting the
virus what we're hearing more and more
stories David about healthy people who
have it who are passing it on you know
II drizelda just did a big interview
with Oprah we said he had no idea that
he had it he's passed it on we've heard
about basketball players that are have
tested positive feeling very healthy
there are reports that they passed it on
how do you deal with something like that
because when you probably should and you
can spread the virus and so that's what
we're concerned about but those people
also can be our frontline because
they're not going to get the virus again
at least in the short term fair as
volunteers helping all of us to protect
the elderly and the people with medical
conditions who can't get the virus
because of what could happen to that why
is 15 days a magic number we keep
hearing 15 days 15 days why is that the
magic number and how realistic is that
really
that's a great question there it is we
just don't know so when we make
interventions like we all have done this
the whole country has come through in
such an amazing a positive way is
classically it takes seven to ten to
twelve days to see the impact of those
changes on the virus because the
incubation period of the virus so the
assumption is that fifteen days we'll
know where we are and the hope is we've
dramatically decreased spread of the
virus if we decrease spread of the virus
we're not going to overwhelm our medical
infrastructure we've been given time to
develop drugs that are new work and
you're just treating the drug and
preventing it from being spread so we
need that time David from where you are
and and what you know how dire is the
medical supply shortage what America's
supply storage is in kind of two buckets
if you will its supplies like the masks
and the gowns and then it's the drugs to
treat it the masks and the gowns we're
starting to see a little bit of easing
of supply it's certainly not where it
needs to be but companies are stepping
up people are making that people are
making hand sanitizers you know
alcohol-based companies are off it's
that part is exciting and I think offers
some hope there in terms of drugs or
therapeutics we're seeing bigger
supplies come in this week and so
obviously when the president announced
that hydroxychloroquine
may be effective against the virus
nationwide doctors started to describe
her for patients and we now go on the
drug much more of a supplies coming in
toward the end of this week and so we're
starting to get a little bit encouraged
that we're gonna hit some of these
supply issues you know I think we're all
stepping up whether they be the
government or doctors or the whole of
America to really make a dip act on this
disease and certainly play offense
instead of defense
hey you just gave me a new phrase
stepping up stay home stay safe step up
all right thank you David agus always
good to have you with us always good to
have you with us